Danny we just want to start by saying
that you know we have a lot of
screenwriters and other artists that
watch our channel and that we recommend
that they see rebel on the rise it's an
excellent film for artists so we just
want to start it out I love that well
yeah the film is very much an artist
manifesto I mean it's literally about
the writing process and about what it
means to be an artist so I think that
your site's perfect for the film Oh
perfect thank you yeah and and it shows
that there's many many ups and downs in
the journey and we don't give away any
spoilers but um so we just want to start
the interview off with that so when you
were writing the film and I realized
that you you found a book in a bookstore
that was the biography from what 2010
yeah 2011 I think when the Solinsky
biography came out right well JD
Salinger Life OK
right and I realize that was one that
was maybe a little more tame about him
it focused more on sort of the positive
if I remember Smee yeah yeah it
certainly wasn't uh I thought it was an
inaccurate but it wasn't out to get him
sure ferry yeah right that's what I had
read in some of them but I will say too
that the film is not just sourced from
one source I mean I read all the
biographies and I interviewed people
that knew him and and so ultimately the
screenplay is informed by many different
sources but the book was the genesis of
it and a huge part of the research does
come from that book okay
did you almost feel as if JD Salinger
was with you at times I mean I know
that's sort of a common question of
people but I mean you know especially
being in the writers experience as
something you've had personally as well
yeah I never felt JD Salinger was with
me although I think he's with me right
now no yeah no I
it was yeah it wasn't really like that
it's more of for me trying to and it's
and it's not exclusive JD Salinger's all
my characters write all my characters no
matter how small the part is is I'm just
trying to get in the headspace of that
character's point of view and so I'm
constantly trying to and I basically
when I write I act out the parts in my
head as I'm writing them and I used to
think I was crazy and then I read an
interview with Aaron Sorkin where he
said he played all the parts as
he bread as he wrote them in his head
and I thought oh I do too
you know it was with his relief that
okay with a great screenwriter of our
times is what he does so and that had
been my process so that's what I'm
constantly just trying to get into the
voice and the headspace of the
characters as I write them that's the
great thing about the Bluetooth
headpiece because you can be doing
something as you're driving and then
people just think you're in an animated
conversation yeah yeah my fiancee says I
look like a crazy person because I walk
around and sometimes I'm doing dialogue
and I so make fun of me and she'll just
say you just did this and you were
talking it's not that's an unfair
accusation even though I know it's true
I say well that's good that you're
living in a parallel universe yeah or
more deeply psychosis either way when
you start writing everyday I'm right so
I have basically the same pattern when
I'm writing sometimes if I'm doing if
I'm in production or it'll it'll change
but if I'm just in a writing phase which
is my favorite to be honest with you
because I love my schedule as a writer
as I wake up I go somewhere have
breakfast and and usually I'll go
somewhere where I can have breakfast and
write and then I'll open my computer so
now it's around 10:30 ish and then I
return emails for about an hour hour and
a half and then I start writing and then
I write for about three to four hours
straight and then I'm done and that is
basically my process and sometimes it
takes me two hours to get started and
then when I get to that two hour mark
and I haven't started that's when
self-loathing comes in so then I do get
started but usually I can get going in
about an hour to an hour and a half it's
a computer that has it's hooked up to
the internet so yeah yeah I'm definitely
stay on the internet because I'm I'm
looking things up all the time is I'm
writing sometimes it's just random
things I'm looking for a synonym for
something and I'll just type go-to
synonym and type in a word and some
synonyms will pop up and so it can be as
simple as that so it's not a distraction
it's awesome no not on the whole I mean
it can be a little bit but but it works
for me and so but that's
that's my schedule what's the longest
writing day you've ever had oh I don't
like to write once I'm get tired because
then I just lose my focus and the
writing is not as good so but yeah yeah
I was for the first two seasons on
Empire I wrote a lot of the show and so
those would turn into sometimes a long
days and where you're writing you're
rewriting an episode and you're doing a
lot of work so sometimes just ten hours
and I don't like it at all and I don't
think the work I think the work suffers
for it so you think you're better at the
three to four hours yeah that's why I do
it I mean it's literally as soon as I
start to lose my focus then just stop
and I don't have writer's block I don't
it's not a very dramatic thing there's
no inspiration I don't wait for
inspiration I say inspiration is for
amateurs amateurs get inspired
professionals just go do it and and it's
not even very dramatic anymore I mean I
just go and I know I'm gonna do it I
mean I know I'm gonna get stuff done and
it's very productive to be honest with
you I find that that I get a lot of
writing done because I don't make a big
deal about it I don't it's not this big
dramatic thing for me I just show up and
then I just get going and like I said it
takes sometimes an hour an hour and a
half to actually get started
occasionally two hours and then we and
then I just start going and I try to be
non-judgmental of it and I don't sit
there and question it or think that I'm
not talented or I just try and do it and
then and then there's a phase when you
have to edit it and go through it and
that can be more you know that's a more
critical part of your brain but I do my
best to not beat myself up about it and
if I don't like something I just change
it I just keep working on it and working
on it and not turn it into some big
melodramatic artists struggle I don't I
don't view it that way at all I will say
one thing that I think could be very
interesting to people that are writers
is is what I do is I outline a script
very meticulously and my outlines are
about 25 pages to 30 pages long and then
when I go to write the actual first
draft I will not
we read one word of what I've written
until I've written the whole script so
for my first pass on a screenplay I
start from the beginning and then I just
go and I go all the way through until
I'm done without having read one word of
it and it takes about three weeks so in
three weeks I've written a whole draft
and it's a lot of fun because there is
no judgment whatsoever I'm just writing
straight through and then I go through
and very meticulously work through the
scenes and that takes two to three weeks
and then in six weeks I have a draft but
it's really two drafts because I've done
one straight through and then one this
sort of meticulous work through and I
will say that the second phase of it the
meticulous work through phase is the
least enjoyable part of the whole
process because it's the most critical
where I just for a couple weeks it's
just I have to work through these scenes
and and and then but I just do it and
then after that I have a draft to work
off of and then there's many drafts
after that but it's it's I have this
nice foundation so going back to what
you said about not making a big deal
about waiting for inspiration
yeah was it always that way for you I
know this was over many years of
figuring this out and for the first
several years I was writing I was deep
in my acting career and writing was more
therapeutic to get my mind off of the
very painful trials and tribulations of
an acting career because it's very
difficult and you get rejected a lot and
all the cliches are absolutely true and
then but I was serious about it but it
was uh you know I think it just took a
while of realising that beating yourself
up and I have no talent or this is
terrible or I oh I'll work with a writer
and they'll say oh that was and I
said don't don't worry about it don't
worry about if it's good or bad just
let's just take a look at it and see
what what could be improved there's no
reason to be so caustic and hostile
about the material it's just words on
its screen you can change them it's just
changing so that's very much something
that guides me in
work so would you say you still spend
about 300 days a year writing Empire no
no I was I was the first two seasons of
Empire I was very active and then season
three I switched to consulting and went
and made revel in the RAI so I have I'm
now season three and four I'm you know
I'm still the executive producer on it
but but I'm not nearly as hands-on as I
was in the first two seasons so you
probably couldn't have written rebel in
the RAI and also Empire at the same time
well I wrote I think I wrote rebel in
the RAI the first couple drafts before
Empire happened and it actually Empire
happening slowed my progress in getting
rebel in there I made because Empire got
made so I ended up working on that but I
ended up directing a lot of episodes of
Empire so that was an amazing experience
for me to transition into directing this
just couldn't have been a better way to
to really learn that craft because you
have to move so quickly and and I'm have
plenty more to learn but it was a great
it was a great start for me when you're
writing and I know you said you had this
writing day where you have your
breakfast you kind of do a few things
get get a lot of like housekeeping
little wood out of the way
is it easier to write in New York versus
LA or the place doesn't really matter
well I love New York City I love being
there I'm just so happy there so for me
I can write anywhere and that's kind of
one of the fun things about writing is I
can be anywhere in the world and I can
write and it's actually pretty cool to
be in some random city somewhere and
some random coffee shop and you're
writing and it's it's like how often
does someone have a job that they can do
anywhere in the world I mean that's a
lot of fun and I'm perfectly productive
in Los Angeles too I just I just love
being in New York and it's a it's just
exciting place to be so can you relate
to JD Salinger's process in terms of
once he sort of crossed over into
meditation and all of that where he
needed to really barricade himself can
you relate to that or um I definitely
don't barricade myself at all actually
right in public places I don't like
being in a quiet room by myself I have a
certain amount of AVD and being in a
quiet room
izo now
and I'm less productive so I actually
like having people around me one of my
head said I listen to music I write two
movie scores so I'm just listening to
movie scores and people are around and
there's an energy and and I find it very
helpful and I just helps me focus but
that's just me so I I the you know the
the isolation of what what mr. Salinger
did is kind of the opposite of of how I
work for new writers I know they're told
to get feedback from other people and I
was just reading an lamotte's bird by
bird and she talked about like writers
conferences and how they can be helpful
but at the same time sometimes the same
you know slashing to the edits is also
stabbing the screenwriter a little bit
you talk about the kindest way to give
somebody honest feedback so you're
actually helping them you're not
wounding them so that they won't go on
well I think that the best way to give
feedback and I'm very very much rely on
feedback and I need notes from people
and it helps me see problems and it's
very important part of my process is
getting feedback but I think that to
keep I mean good feedback is when it's
just about the script it doesn't get
personal it doesn't you know talk about
bigger ideas of whether you can do this
or not area of talent or not where it's
literally just about how to make this
script or this story better in areas
that are problematic and I think that I
don't I think it's really important when
someone's getting feedback that they
talk to a few people that they get
feedback from from maybe three people
because there could be feedback that
someone gives you that they're very
passionate about but they don't know
what they're talking about that it's bad
feedback that they're just not good at
giving feedback there's a lot of people
that aren't good at giving feedback
right so you want you want a few
opinions and for me when I start hearing
from two or three people the same
problem they're having well there's
probably a problem there and there's
probably something I need to address and
one of my favorite parts of writing is
when I take a problem and then I fix it
and then it's
good that's that's so exciting because
you have something that was bad that's
now good and just it's just it's like
you have a hole and instead of having a
ditch you have a statue there instead so
it's a very bet I can only get that get
there when by getting feedback from
people you had early success in your
screenwriting career as you had your
first screenplay option for like a few
thousand dollars I think in the
beginning and then you wrote for six
years and you were able to sell recount
to HBO
so most people would have given up in
that six year period especially now and
then everybody wants everything like
that
why didn't you that's a great question I
mean the early success wasn't really
success I would say I wouldn't really
call it early success I it was I don't
even view it that way I view it as six
years of no one wanting my stuff and it
was you know some random person who was
very kind was interested in a script but
it wasn't as if it was all of a sudden I
made it and it's happening now so it
really was a six seven year journey to
selling my first project which was
recount and why I didn't give up I think
is because I had something to say and I
loved writing these scripts and they
were important to me and I loved working
on stories and it just was artistically
extremely fulfilling where my acting
career was very frustrating and
sometimes I and I worked I did really
some worked on some terrific shows that
I'm really proud of but I wasn't
actually getting to act very much so
even when you're working you know I
would do episodes of Gilmore Girls and I
would do four episodes of season and I
would work on it a day or two and that
would be one of my only jobs for six
months so it's really about seven days
on set over a six month period so what
am i doing the rest of the time I'm
auditioning and trying to get new jobs
but that's an hour a day maybe so really
it was it was a creative outlet for me
of taking my creative energy and putting
it into something where I can actually
just go do it where as an actor you have
to be picked to go do it and then you
rarely get picked so I
just found it fulfilling but I also was
getting rejected and left and right
script after script and agents managers
production company everyone didn't want
my work for six seven years and I think
I got to a point where I asked myself
well this is not going well what are you
what do you want from this what what are
you doing and I sort of asked myself
would I and it's one of the key
questions in the movie would I do this
for the rest of my life if I got nothing
in return and I thought yeah I would and
then I just kept writing and then
eventually it wasn't as if six months
later cracked the champagne it was maybe
three years later that I sold recount as
a pitch to HBO and then just kind of
went on from there but there was a
certain peace in knowing that it wasn't
about it wasn't about selling something
or success even though I really wanted
it I wasn't and what you know wasn't a
kumbaya moment but there was a peace in
knowing that well whatever happens you
just keep writing so just keep writing
and that's what I did yeah and I saw
that you willed that I think did two
parts of the movie that that premise
yeah which i think is a big eye-opener
to a lot of people that's something that
most people may not be ready for yeah
and look at what JD Salinger did right
he stopped publishing at the height of
his fame and then continued writing for
45 years for nothing in return and he
wrote every day and he just did it
because he just wanted to write and I
think to me that's what makes this story
a profound story is the journey of the
artist and he goes from being a young
man who all he wants his success to
being an older writer which all he wants
is to just create his art and nothing
else and that's that's the journey
that's the the Aesop fable of this movie